it's easy to see that this cast didn't
just join this film in hopes of some
accolades come award season they also
seem to thoroughly enjoy their fellow
cast and crew members and the meshing
between the returning and new cast
members were no exception to this Austin
Butler joined the cast this time around
and working with co-star Timothy shalam
was a highlight for him we bonded
immediately I really love him a lot and
uh I've been a huge fan of his work in
fact this cast was close enough that was
even happy to bring his dad to set when
the movie wrapped filming the actor
posted a selfie of him with his father
in the desert where they filmed
captioned desert dad